the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
shall we start let me just say this is a
great adventure for me to be here all on
my own teaching a course that involves
learning from data so it's exciting
subject and a lot of linear algebra goes
into it so it's sort of a second course
in linear algebra can I just
you'll know what so there is a stellar
site established and that will be the
basic thing that we use this is a public
site method mit.edu
learning from data and so a book is
coming pretty quickly as we speak or
after we speak and that site has the
table of contents of the book which
would give you an idea of what could be
in the course and I and I printed out a
copy for everybody just of that one page
that's probably the final first and last
handout maybe with with the table of
contents which you'll see there and also
you'll see there the first two sections
of the book which is what I'll talk
about today and and on a little bit in
to Friday so that's that's linear
algebra of course because the course
sort of begins with linear algebra
actually things that you would know from
1806 but you but this is a way to say
this is really important stuff so that's
what I'll do today I'd like to do some
start on the linear algebra today
and here's the great facts about the
course at least we knew there were so we
taught it last year several of us
together and we knew there wouldn't be a
final exam but we imagined there might
be quizzes along the way but then we
couldn't think of anything to put on the
quizzes so we canceled those but you do
learn a lot nevertheless and so I guess
we base the grades on the homeworks so
the homeworks will be partly linear
algebra questions and partly online you
know like recognizing handwriting
stitching images together many other
things and I'll talk about those as we
go right good yeah
so this that's the general picture and
I'll say more about it today and I could
answer any question about it so we're
getting videotaped so if anybody's
bashful sit at the far back but it'll be
fun yeah you may know the videos for
1806 so this is like the next step 1806
five that's pretty exciting for me so
any question or shall I do a little math
why not and then and then I'll say a
little more about the course just so you
have an idea of what what's ahead yeah
and it looks like this room is exactly
the right size to me so I'm pleased okay
so so what's the deal in linear algebra
let me I'll start forgive me if I start
with what I do the very first day in
1806 which is multiply a matrix by a
vector and then I'll graduate to
multiplying a matrix by a May
tricks so that and you will say I know
that stuff but do you know it the right
way do you think of the multiplication
the right way so let me tell you what I
believe to be the right way so let me
take a matrix say two three five one one
seven and three four twelve okay and
I'll always call matrices a okay so
first step is just a times X a times a
vector so I multiply a a by let's say x1
x2 x3 and how do I look at that answer
so the choice is think of the rows of
the matrix or think of the columns and
if you think of the rows which is the
standard way to multiply you would take
the dot product so the first way is the
first way is dot product of Row Row
dotted with X right 2 X 1 plus X 2 plus
3 X 3 it gives you the answer a
component at a time that's the low level
way the good way to see it is vector
wise see this as X 1 multiplies that
first column X 2 times the second column
1 1 7 and X 3 times the third column 3 4
12
good so it's a combination of vectors
and of course it produces a vector and
here we have a three by three matrix and
our vectors are in r3 and most vectors
will be in r3 or RN for this course so
that's the right answer and of course
the first component is 2 X 1 + 1 X 2 + 3
X 3 the same 2 1 3 the same dot product
comes out right but you see it like sort
of all at once instead of piecemeal so
that's you know part of the course I
guess part of what I hope to get across
is thinking of a matrix of a matrix as a
whole thing not just a bunch of 9 or or
M times n numbers but thinking of it as
a as a thing a matrix multiplies a
vector to give another vector yeah think
so that when I say ax that you
immediately think that you immediately
think okay ax has a clear meaning it's a
combination of the columns of a so now
let me take that next step and the next
step is think about all combinations of
the columns of a we take the matrix a
and we take all X's and we imagine all
the outputs and what I want to ask you
is what does that look like if I just
take 1 X 1 vector X I get a vector
output takes a vector to a vector but
now I take all X's the hole all of
vectors X in or in 3d and I get all
these answers and I think of them all
together and so I've got a bunch of
vectors infinitely many vectors actually
and the question is what if I plot those
infinitely many vectors what do I have
and the beauty of linear algebra is that
questions like this
you can answer them and they you
intuitively see it you certainly see it
in 3d and you kind of have the right and
the right idea in ten dimensions even
though most of us don't see too well in
10 D in our 10 but here we got three
okay so so do you see what I'm saying
I'm taking all X's so now so all a X
gives us a big bunch of vectors and that
collection of vectors is called the
column space of a it's a space in other
words that that's the keyword there the
column space of a and I'll just write it
as C of a when I need a letters for it
okay so I'm going to ask you what does
this column space look like and that
depends on the matrix sometimes the
column space would be the whole of r3
sometimes it's a smaller set in r3 or
space
do you know what it is in this case do I
get do I get all of 3d out of these guys
by choosing all X 1 and X 2 and X 3 it
seemed like if it was a random matrix
the answer would be surely yes if the
random 3x3 matrix is its column space is
going to be all of our three its columns
are going to be independent its rows are
going to be independent it's going to be
invertible it's going to be great but is
this matrix what's up with that matrix
no it's not right
so what do I get instead of all of our
three I get a plane yeah if you get that
in sight so by taking all X's
everybody's with me all X's here so so
that means that like it fills in
whatever and well because it's linear
algebra it's gonna be likely all of our
three
or a plane or even a line what let me
just bat over here for a moment
give me a matrix which would whose
column space would only be a line all
one's okay wow that's a let me liven it
up a little three three three eight
eight eight I think okay so I think that
the combinations of those columns are
all on the same line look that says that
the column space is just a line and I
would say then that the matrix so a
column space of this a is a line another
way I could say this is that the rank of
the matrix is one the rank is sort of
the dimension of the column space well
not sort of that's what it is the rank
is the dimension of the column see
everybody sees that you get a line
because any combination x1 of that plus
x2 of that plus x3 of that is is going
to go in in along that line here's the
first column here's the second column
they're all on a line so I'll never get
off that line if I allow all X's I'll
get the whole line
now here you said not a line right what
was what was the column space for this
guy plain now why isn't it all of our
three what what is what do you see that
special there because it is special
that's making the column space sort of
special a plane instead of the whole
thing yeah what's up with these three
columns the third column is the sum of
these two so the first column is fine to
3/5 second column is in a different
direction and when I take combinations
of the first two columns what will I get
sorry to keep asking your questions but
that's that's
anyway that's what I always do so so so
the fur the combinations of those first
two columns are a plane because they're
in different everybody kind of sees that
picture we've got one column one going
that way and call them to go in that way
and then if I take any multiple of
column one I've got a whole line any
multiple of column two and then when I
put the two together it fills in the
fills in the plane yeah yeah our ear
intuition says that's right so this is a
matrix of rank what's the rank of this
matrix two because it's got two
independent columns but the third column
is dependent the third column is a
combination of the others so this is
matrices like this are really the
building blocks of linear algebra
they're the building blocks of data
science they're rank one matrices and
let me show you a special way to think
write those rank one matrices I think of
this matrix as column vector 1 1 1 times
the row vector 1 3 8 so it's a column
times a row that's a rank one matrix do
you see that it's a that's a true
multiplication there it looks a little
weird but it's a three by one matrix
times a 1 by 3 matrix these numbers have
to be the same and then the output is 3
by 3 and it's that and you see that it
factors so I'm going to move on to that
idea the next idea coming up will be
that that we we can see well that's
coming that we're going to see matrices
in with two factors okay let me let me
move to that but but they're back for
this original matrix
okay so what's with this the column
space is a plane so if I think about now
the key idea of independent columns how
many independent columns have I got here
to correct to the third column if I want
to especially pick on that one so I
often go left to right so I'll say the
first guy's good second guy's good the
third guy not is not independent of the
others so I just have two independent
columns and those are those two columns
would be a basis for the column space so
that's the like the critical idea of
linear algebra that's what you compute
with you find a basis and and every
thing in the column space is a
combination of these including that is
also that's already a combination of
those but everything else in the column
space is a combination of those two so
so there a basis for it okay so you have
the idea of a times X you have the idea
of column space of a which allows all XS
then now we're moving into the idea of
independent columns and the number of
independent columns is is the rank so
the rank shall I write that somewhere
maybe here the rank is the number of
independent columns
and right now what do I mean by
independent columns well let's just see
what that means by by using it are we
good I'm I know I'm reviewing here but
allow me for this first class and part
of next time also to review but you'll
see something new fact why don't we see
something new right away let me follow
up on the idea of Independence in a
systematic way so here's my matrix a can
I write that again two three five one
one seven and this guy was the sum of
those okay so that's my matrix a ok so
let's start from scratch and find a
basis for the column space in in the
most natural way so I'm going to take a
basis I'm going to what's a basis a
basis is independent columns so all
three together would not be a basis but
there have to be not just independent
but but they have to fill the space
their combinations have to fill the
space so so two three five can let's say
I want to create a basis I'll call the
matrix C column a basis for the column
space so here's a natural way to do it I
look at the first column it's not zeros
if it was all zeros I wouldn't want that
in a basis but it's not so I put it in
so that's the first vector in my basis
then I go on to the second column if
that column was four six ten what would
I do if that second column was four six
ten would I put it in the basis no but
one one seven is okay right one one
seven is
different direction it's not a
combination of what we've already got so
I say okay that adds something new put
it in then I move on to the third column
do I put that into a basis you know the
answer by now no because I'm looking to
see is it a combination of these guys
and it is it's one of that plus one of
that so it's not independent so I've
I've finished now I've got a matrix C
which was like taken directly from a and
I kept only independent columns and I
worked from left to right and I can see
that right away now that the rank is to
the column rank I should say the column
rank a number of independent columns is
too good now comes a key step I'm gonna
produce a third matrix R which is going
to tell me how to get these columns from
these columns and its shape is going to
be well its shape I don't have any
choice this is 3 by 2 so R has to be to
buy something so so so I'm like so I
guess it has to be 2 by 3 because I want
to come out this way 2 by 3 what am I
gonna do here I'm just going to put in
the numbers are that make this correct
so this is a first matrix factorization
it's not well it is a famous one
actually when we see it we'll recognize
what it is it's but it's famous in
teaching the near algebra but now
actually see times are columns times
rows has become very very important in
large scale numerical linear algebra
yeah so let's figure out what goes into
our okay so what's going in what am I
thinking here I'm putting in our that
tel so every one of these columns is a
combination of these that's the whole
point and I'm just going to put in the
numbers that you need so what goes in
the first column of our what goes in the
first column of our so I want to look
what combination of that column and that
column gives me this one yeah one zero
one zero because you remember how we
multiply a matrix by a vector when I
multiply that matrix by that vector I
take one of this plus zero of that I see
it vector wise and of course I get it
right and what about the second column
of R so the second column should be the
combination that produces the second
column of a correctly what will that be
zero one thanks and finally the third
column one one yes right because one of
this plus one of this produces the third
column so so all I did was put in the
right numbers there really right and
this is correct now a SC times R and so
that's this is like what I've done here
is like the first two pages of section
1.1 in these notes so 1.1 and actually
so I tell you literally what happened
earlier this year I wish this I wrote I
wrote this down with a different example
and then I realized something that that
sitting here in front of me was the
first great theorem in linear algebra
the fact that the column rank equals the
row rank the fact that if I have a
matrix where that column plus that
column gives that one oh so what am I
going to say here I'm getting nervous
about it I believe that a combination of
the rows gives 0 do you believe that I
mean you got to believe it this is like
a linear algebra the matrix is not
invertible it's square but the columns
are dependent so the rows have to be
dependent and I don't exactly see I
there's some combination of that row and
that row that gives that one and when I
of course when I looked at the first
column I thought ok it's going to be
it's going to be too easy one of that
and one of that gives that but then my I
went over to the second column and I
realize it's not easy at all so you're
entitled to pull out a your phone and
figure this out but there is some damn
combination of those of those two rows
it gives the third row it's otherwise
like the course is over we stop but well
maybe we're gonna find it or somehow
yeah yeah so so that's this is the
theorem so I so I have to tell you I
mean you know I was like really pleased
so the first two pages got two more
pages to follow up on that idea that
here we were seeing something that I
sort of proved in 1806 but not you know
not in the first lecture that's for sure
and I'm not not maybe so clearly but now
I can I try to prove it
so and so here's the there won't be a
lot of proofs in this class but this is
such an important fact a equals CR is
important factorization and and out of
it we can connect them so what am I
saying I'm saying that all that that
that the row so what's the row rank yeah
I could go back up here what's the row
rank what's the row space so the row
rank is going to be the definite the
dimension of that space so so I look at
my matrix a what's the row space of a
I'm gonna look at its rows now maybe
just so we don't get a whole new letters
for the row space there I'm for me the
row space of a of a matrix so so first
of all tell me in words what it is
what's the row space of the matrix all
combinations of the rows all
combinations of the rows that's the
space so I would take all combinations
of those rows to get combinations of the
rows I well two ways I can get
combinations of the rows and the way
I'll do it is
I'll just transpose the matrix so those
rows become columns and then I'm back to
what I did so the row space of a is the
column space of a transpose and and this
has the advantage that we don't
introduce a new letter so it's it'll be
the column space of a transpose so we
don't introduce a new letter we keep the
convention that vectors are column
vectors which would be the MATLAB and
and Julia and Python convention so is
that okay
the row space is the combination of
these rows but I'll flip i'll make them
stand up 2 1 3 2 2 B column vectors so
it's a totally different space and
actually in my I happen to take a 3 by 3
example so that the column space is part
of our three and the row space is also
part of our three because my matrix is
three by three a better example I mean
and the whole point of data data doesn't
come in square matrices fortunately for
us data very very often comes in
matrices but the to the columns might be
sampled might be patients and the rows
might be diseases or something I mean
they're they're different spaces so
matrices are not likely to be square but
anyway we're good here okay okay so the
row space
now now can I come back to the proof
because we what I want to say is that
the proof of this fundamental fact is
staring at us but we don't quite see it
yet and I want to see it so I claim that
these rows are a basis for the row space
and we already saw that these columns
our basis for the column space and two
equals two right two vectors here or a
basis for the column space now if I can
see why this shows me that these two
vectors are a basis for the row space
then then I have my example is right
both both of these will give to the
column rank is to two columns the row
rank is to two rows so
I have to explain why I believe that
these two rows are a basis for the row
space right with me I have to prove to
see why first are there so when I say
basis what do I have to check basis is
is just is the critical idea it I have
to check that they're independent so I
haven't got too many vectors I've got
any extra vectors in there and I also
have to check that their combinations
produce all the rows should I say that
again that's because that's what I'm
going to check I'm gonna check that
those guys are independent well you can
see that they're independent and I'm
going to check that the that their
combinations produce all three of these
rows if we didn't create those numbers
for this purpose but what I'm saying is
they work so I claim that this is a
basis because what what combination of
those two rows would produce this this
first row yeah let me just ask you that
what combination what numbers should I
multiply these two rows by to get the
first row of any two and one and where
do you find two and one
it's sitting there in see what I'm and
will it work again does three of this
plus one of that give three one four yes
so far so good
does five of this and seven of that see
I'm multiplying I guess I'm doing matrix
multiplication a sort of backward wait
or a different different way I'm taking
combinations of the rows of the second
guy that's another way that one
careful thing about matrix
multiplication is you can do it a lot of
ways it comes out the same every way and
each way tells you something so 5 of
that row plus 7 of that row sure enough
is here do you see that that is not like
accident that that the proof is really
to look at this multiplication C times
are two ways look at it first as
combinations of columns of C to give the
columns look at it second to get as
combinations of the rows of R and that
produces the rows so that factorization
a equals C R was what's the key idea and
actually this R that we've come up with
has a name
anybody remember enough 1806 here's a
like have you all taken 1806 I'm no I
see us how many have let's yes okay good
for a while 1806 was taught in a very
abstract way I said what's going on but
anyway so if you took it that semester
you maybe never heard of the column
space I'm not sure or by a different
name it has another name
what's its other name the column space
of a matrix range I think it's the range
yeah right right yep yep and of course
it's all this is fundamental in
mathematics so of course it everything
here is is has different languages and
different emphasis but you see what the
emphasis is here okay so you see the
proof that a equals C R is just reveals
everything so it's a first idea of a
factorization of a matrix
and and we've multiplied see times are
now I could just say cuz so that's
really you've seen the now the main
point of section 1.1 of the notes to
come up with that factorization and that
conclusion and and and you see why C has
the same number of the number of columns
of C will the number of rows of our and
those are the column rank and the row
rank yeah it's just pretty neat and here
was the special case where those column
space the column space is all multiples
of you it's a line through you the row
space is all multiples of V it's a line
through V and that's the basic building
block yeah can I just say another little
word before I push on beyond CR that
that this has become if you have a giant
matrix like size 10 to the fifth that's
that you know you can't put that into
fast memory you it's it's it's a mess
how do you deal with a matrix of size 10
to the fifth when you cannot deal with
all the entries that that's just not
possible
will you sample it so later in the
course we'll be doing random sampling of
a matrix so how could your sample a
matrix so you have a matrix of course
you're not looking at it because but
it's and you want to get some typical
columns okay here's the natural idea you
just look at any x x when you take let X
be a random vector random vector R and R
and of so it's got M rows and one column
it's a vector and what can I say about
ax
it's in what spaces it in column space
thanks that was the first idea in this
in this lecture ax is in the column
space so if you want a random vector in
the column space I wouldn't suggest it
just randomly pick one of the columns
better to take a mixture of columns by
taking a random vector X and looking at
looking at ax and if you wanted a
hundred random vectors you take a
hundred random X's and that would give
you a pretty good idea in many cases of
what what the column space looks like
that would be enough to work with often
yeah okay okay can I just throw in
another question so so ax is in the
column space of a let me just ask you
this question is is ABC X is that in the
column space of a suppose I have
matrices a B and C and a vector X and I
take their product does that give me
something in the column space of a yes
good for you why how do you know that
yeah it's a time something right putting
parentheses in the right place is the
key to linear algebra and they're okay
it's a question just occurred to me and
I thought well I wonder if you'd do it
okay so we have still time to multiply
matrices oh I was going to say about C
and R so these are real columns from a
but R is the rows are not taken directly
from the rows of a actually there's a
name for this it's called the row
reduced echelon form of the matrix and
it's a big goal in in 1806 it has the
identity there and then the other
columns are tell you the right
combinations yep yep another big
factorization would be to take columns
from from a so this is another so I'll
put maybe or and we won't be doing this
for a month
we could start take columns of columns
of a and put them in to see if they were
independent and suppose I took rows of a
now I'm going to take literally rows of
a and put them into or well so I call it
our twiddle or something cuz it'll be a
different R I'm gonna use actually not
I'm not going to use those rows but I'm
gonna take two actual rows of a then
what so that's important factorization
but it's not correct I wouldn't if I
took two other rows of our it wouldn't
work so you have to put in the middle
some two-by-two matrix you that makes it
correct just you'll see on the in the in
that section 1.1 that I got excited and
wrote a page about seeing you are yep
solid just mention that okay so now I'm
ready oh I wanted to say something about
the course decided thing about mass but
there is this course so what's up so
there be linear algebra problems but but
what makes this course special is the
other homeworks which are online and you
would use let's see in principle you
could use any of the languages
MATLAB Python which has become the
biggest most used for deep learning or
Julia which is the hot
new language and so last semester the
problems oh so what happened last year
well everything in this course is ode to
a professor who visited from University
of Michigan professor rah-rahs Rao
who taught gave most of the lectures a
year ago brought these homework problems
online homework problems so that people
brought laptops to class and we did
things in class and so he had had and
has very successful course in EE in
Michigan and but he was a PhD from here
and he came back on a sabbatical and he
created this got us started and we
really owe a lot to him
also professor Adelman was involved with
this course and you may be know that he
created julia how many like know what
julia is Oh wonderful
that will make his day he tells me every
time I see him Julia's good and I tell
him I believe it ok anyway and it's
become the professor Johnson in 1806 has
used Julia and every semester Stephen
Johnson gives in the first week a
tutorial on Julia and so he's that's
arranged and I promised to tell you
where where when that is so I think if
you don't know anything about Julia try
to go it's in Stata it's on Friday at
5:00 5:00 to 7:00 so Julia from
professor Johnson
so he's done this multiple times he's
good at it
so that's McQueen Oh yet what I I guess
I'm hoping that you'll have an option to
use all any of the three languages but
the the the online thing that we give
you was created in Julia so professor
Rao had to learn Julia last spring and
though their class did too and there was
a certain amount of bitching about it
but I think with maybe one exception who
still got an A we everybody was kind of
okay and was glad to learn Julia and
professor Rao now uses Julia entirely
like so he's creating a new on-ramp with
Julia
MATLAB by the way has just issued an
on-ramp to deep learning that I'll tell
you about and probably get a MATLAB
somebody from math works to to say
something about it yeah so that's what's
coming that we don't quite know exactly
how we'll organize those homeworks would
just take the first one and see see what
happens
so I'll certainly say more about
homeworks when when the maybe even
Friday but are there other questions
that I should answer so because some
people will be thinking okay am I going
to do this or am I gonna sit in six oh
three six or some other course in deep
learning anything on your mind and you
can email me so we will have a stellar
site and you'll see all the the TAS are
still to be named but the wonderful
thing is that undergraduates who took
this course last year are volunteering
to be graders for you guys so they will
know what those online homeworks were
about it okay so that's what's it's a
sort of first word about what's coming
about about the language okay
I'm gonna finish by a very important
topic multiplying a times B oh look
cleaning board so I know I want multiply
multiply a matrix by a vector
okay everybody knows how to do it you
take a row of a so you take a row of a
and you take a column of B and you take
that dot product so you get dot product
row row got column row dot that's again
low level like okay for beginners but we
want to see that matrix multiplication a
B in a deeper way and the deeper way is
columns times rows columns of a rows of
B columns times rows well we had a
column times a row right that was this
rank one example we had our column times
a row and it produced a matrix and
that's what it looks like and it's rank
was one so those are what
we have a good so it's a combination of
it's very like ax I'm really just
extending the ax idea to a B so so this
this is the old way a new way is columns
so there's column K it will multiply
sure enough it multiplies r okay
everybody sees that it will happen that
way if you do it the old way when you do
a dot product of something here
something here you're doing these
multiplications and when you hit column
K here you hit row K there so so these
are connected so so I get things like
column K of a times R okay of B and I
don't know what notation to you so I
just wrote them wrote the words okay
but now that's one piece of the of the
fun of the final answer a B that's a
rank one piece that's a like a building
block so I add from k equal 1 tom 1
times Row one column one of a times Row
one of B plus da plus column K plus and
of course I stop it column in of a times
row in so it's a sum of outer products
some of so everybody sees a sum because
I I have column 1 times Row 1 column K
times R ok call them n times row in and
then I add those pieces it's just the
generalization of a X 2 matrix B there
so it's the sum of
m'kay rogue of a Roque of B and maybe we
should we check that that gives us the
right answer or maybe I won't do that
here but it it's it's all we're doing is
the same multiplications in a different
order actually let's just quit with one
minute we can figure out how many
multiplications are there how many
multiplications to do a M by n matrix a
time's the end by P matrix B so that's a
times B how many individual numbers
because this is determine the cost of it
how many numbers would we need well
suppose we do it the old way by in inner
product row x column so how many how
many multiplications to do a row times I
call them and get one entry in the
answer n right the row has length in the
column has length in n multiplications
so that's N and now how many of those do
I have to do MP because what's the size
of this answer the size of this answer
is n by P okay so if I do they do it in
that old order like n multiplications to
do a dot product and I've got this many
dot products in the answer so I've got M
and P multiple multiplies now suppose I
do it this way
how many multiplications to do one of
those guys to multiply a column by a row
to multiply a column by a row this this
is an M by one and this is a 1 by P one
column one row
how many multiplications for that guy in
P and how many of those ranked ones do I
have to do you got it it's MP times in
now it's the other way was was n times
MP so it gives the same answer MN p
mostly in fact they're exactly the same
multiplications just a different order
okay we're at 155 thanks for coming
today I'll talk more about the class and
about linear algebra on Friday thank you